Cool.
And we'll we'll send a recording out to
the learner list, right?
Yeah, exactly.
Sure.
I should have a screenshot.
All right. Firstly, hello everyone.
Welcome to our first
online talk.
Um I think one of the reasons that
really inspired
I'll try again.
One of the things that really inspired
this talk for us was this whole premise
that
it's been about 2 years and the AI
models seem to just be stuck
in demo land.
And we've seen a lot of apps get
actually built and shipped to production
for some companies.
And we just figured we'd share some of
these techniques for most of April.
With exactly how some people are
addressing some of the problems that we
have.
Um as you have questions, as you have
thoughts, we'd love to make this more
engaging and actually like welcome you
to like uh ask whatever you want.
And then if you have topics that you
think are worth mentioning, mention
those as well and we'll try and cover
them.
But I'll give you a quick background on
who we are and then we'll get to the
meat of it, which hopefully is going to
be the most fun part, which is actually
coding.
And talking about scenarios and how to
make them work.
Um so I'm Vaibhav, I'm one of the
co-founders
of Boundary and we make BAML. Uh it was
uh and we'll be using that mostly for
work today, but in effect any of the
techniques we use can be done with any
of the
um
uh AI layers of your choice.
And our goal is to really just share
techniques.
Dex.
Yeah, what's up? I'm Dex. I'm the
founder of a company that spends most of
my days building tools called Human
Layer,
uh helping people deploy safer, more
reliable AI applications. Call them
agents if you if you insist, but uh I
think we're going to blur that line in
the next couple talks anyways.
Cool.
Um let's talk about a Go ahead. You're
good. I was just going to say like I I I
I think let me let me know if I read
this right, Vaibhav, but I guess the
idea is like let's do really hard
problems with tiny models to prove that
like with the right techniques and the
right prompting and the right kind of
surrounding code, you can even get small
models to do impressive things because
then go apply that to actual big like
frontier models and you'll be able to do
incredible things.
That's kind of the goal. Like if we can
do this with small models, we can
probably get away with very large very
large models doing
doing things as well.
Um and I I personally have this belief
that like GPT-3.5 honestly was already
pretty good for a lot of scenarios.
There's some scenarios where it doesn't
work for.
But I've seen people ship really
impressive pipelines. I think the only
problem that I've seen be a struggle for
a lot of models has been SVG generation.
But honestly now with the new image
model that GPT-4 released, it's possible
that that actually got a lot better.
Just because of how much cleaner the
images are getting.
But we can talk about that later.
Um let's talk about the topic at hand
today, large-scale classification. So
when we talk about large-scale
classification, there's a lot of
different applications that people have
here.
And specifically, I want to narrow down
and articulate some of these
articulations, but how many of you have
actually had
um how many of you have actually like um
dealt with needing to classify, let's
say, over 100 things in your
uh in your AI pipelines?
You can just type in the chat if you'd
like.
What
What we've seen what kind of domains
have people worked in? If you want to
share like the domains that you worked
in, that might help us um
uh make sure that we can contextualize
as much as possible for today's
conversation.
Some of the applications that we've seen
has been mostly in the medical industry.
Has been in the uh or regulatory docs
have been very very common.
Uh there's been a lot of stories in the
manufacturing space. We've seen some
spaces in the
um
uh in the world of MCP
where how do you deal with an MCP server
that has over a thousand tools?
Because LLMs are not going to produce
that very well.
And then we've also seen that really be
true in like routing agents. Cuz if you
have a routing agent with more than 20
routes that it can route to,
we sometimes see degradation of
performance where it starts to pick the
slightly wrong uh routes out there.
So let's talk about how
um how we could go and address this
problem. And I think to address this
problem, the best thing to do is just
start off with like diagrams.
The biggest thing that we often see is
Let me go ahead and
open the scalar draw.
The biggest problem with all these
systems
is that
they're often not very probable. And the
minute a system becomes non-probable, it
really becomes hard to go edit because
now you're at the mercy of the model
updating to actually give you the
results that you want.
And that just isn't uh
that's just a sad world to live in
because now you're stuck waiting for
GPT-26 to come out.
And if GPT-26 doesn't come out that
year, then you're finally just waiting
and twiddling your thumbs.
And the problem with tweaking just the
prompt is that the prompt is very
Our prompt is actually very very hard
um
to go edit yourself. I'm actually going
to get a mouse really fast. Give me 1
second. Dex,
you want to start uh
Um yeah, I can start sketching a couple
things here. So um
I think
I'm curious like when when
when when Vaibhav says probing, maybe
drop in the chat like what is what does
that mean to you? Or actually, okay,
you're back. Um also, if you give me
co-host, I can like help mute people and
stuff like that.
Yeah, let me give you co-host really
fast.
Sorry, technical technical setup stuff.
There you go. I'm added as co-host. I
didn't get to the checklist.
Okay, cool.
Okay, so I'm going to start screen
sharing really fast.
Um and talk about how this works at the
very top level. So obviously, we can do
a very simple thing where we have
some LLM and if this LLM is given a what
we do in this LLM
is we give it a prompt.
And we give it a list of categories.
And I think the solution that most
people have is somehow they add
Oops, sorry.
They take this list of categories and
then they just
uh
put this into the prompt somehow and
then they hope that the LLM
picks from these categories. I think
that's like the most naive solution that
we can do.
Now, you can do a little bit better
Where you then
um
where you then go ahead and instead of
putting it directly in the prompt,
you're kind of putting it in the prompt,
but like there's a special part of the
prompt
um that is
the schema. And specifically, you add
the categories to the schema.
And like the the opening highway of
doing this, right, is like it it
basically is injecting JSON schema-ish
things into the system prompt in a
special way, right?
Exactly.
So I got to one way to do it. Obviously,
you can do this in BAML as well. But the
problem that you run into when you go do
this is you're still not really able to
probe. The only thing you can really
probe is this category list.
And that I think is the most naive
solution that we can do.
sorry, when you say probe, you mean like
make small changes and see how they
affect the outputs, right?
Like what do you mean by probe?
Yeah, I I think um I come from like an
electrical engineering background, so
perhaps that's where my brain is going.
But the hardest part about like
circuits, whenever you do circuit design
on any chip, is you obviously once the
chips get really small, you can't really
introspect them in any way.
So often points, what you'll do is
you'll build like little detection
points
um where like you can actually go ahead
and like go and measure and like
manipulate the inputs or measure the
input at certain points.
The problem with LLMs
it yeah, exactly. Jonathan got it. The
problem with AI pipelines is we don't
really get these probing points and we
don't really get an area to manipulate
this. Right now, the only real point
that we have to manipulate these is the
category list.
But if the category list is like
massive,
how do you get LLMs to actually do what
you do? So let's talk about the most
trivial solutions that people have might
have seen before.
But option one, once your category list
gets really massive, is
you take your category list
Oops.
And instead of putting it into here,
you actually put it into a
um
Oh.
Sorry. You put it into a
uh vector database.
And I'll talk about why a vector
database in a second. It doesn't
actually have to be a vector database.
So you push your category list into
here.
And once your category list lives in a
vector database, then what you have is
instead of
your query
instead of your user query coming in and
immediately taking the entire category
list and going with it,
what we do instead is we draw
into here and then we set down a smaller
list of categories.
And then we go into and then we only
pass those in instead.
And this can do a couple of nice things
for us.
But instead of all the categories I've
selected, now we're able to prune this
down to whatever count the LLM can go
deal with.
Um
So hierarchical categories and multiple
prompts is um
is often what people think about, but
often what I find is that actually leads
to a lot more confusion.
And the reason that leads to a lot more
confusion with hierarchical categories
is because most people don't have clear
definitions of hierarchies and
hierarchies end up bleeding over a lot
more.
So it ends up being a little bit more
troublesome. And I'll talk about a
technique of how you can use
hierarchical categorization
with this vector database technique to
get way better results.
But I think the general rule of thumb is
every single LLM, no matter which one
you use, operates really well on some
count of categories.
But I think the way that you think about
which count of categories, like how many
categories it's able to selectively
select from
really varies based on the categories
themselves.
And I think this is another part that a
lot of people overlook. Um and I
apologize for not writing code right up
front, but I think it will help to have
some framing of diagrams before we go
and code it up.
Um but let's say I have category A and
category B
over here. And if category A and
category B are completely disjoint, I
can have a lot more of these categories.
Like I can have up to Z if they're all
totally disjoint. But the minute I start
having category A and category B overlap
with each other
it becomes really hard for an LLM to
pick the right ones.
So if I have like um
if I have
um
if I have like five categories, I
but they're all really really closely
overlapped with like very very small
nuances differences
it's just not going to perform very well
on an LLM scenario. I probably need a
smaller prompt that is really good at
disjointing only these two categories
separately from each other to identify
when it's one or the other or could be
either one.
But if I have categories that are
totally separate
then it doesn't really matter.
Then we can get away with a lot more
categories in the same prompt. In the
case of like MCP tools
most MCP tools are very very disjoint
from each other.
Uh sometimes there's overlap, but most
of the time they're very disjoint, so we
can get away with having a lot more. In
the case of like hierarchical categories
and hierarchical organization there's
actually a technique that we found works
really well.
Um at least anecdotally um in production
that seems to work.
But let's talk about what is nice about
this approach.
Now
there's this thing here that we all made
an assumption of
in our current approach
where the things going into the vector
database
are going to be exactly the categories
and we just apply an embedding on the
categories and we put them in.
But again, we don't really have any
probe points in the system.
We have a couple of probe points. We
added another one, which is we can
control how many
like exactly how we can control the
count of these categories.
We can control
in your vector search. Yeah. Exactly.
It's your top K in your vector search.
So we get one control point. You want to
label that, Dex?
And then we get another control point,
which is like we can choose what
embedding system
what embeddings model we use.
So now we have two control
too, right? Like can would you embed
like a description of the category with
the actual like if it's like Apple,
orange, banana, would you describe that
as well, put it in the embedding? So
exactly. So that's where I would say
like there's like a separate option here
that I'm going to draw out where a lot
of people I think overlook this concept
as a whole
which is the naive thing to do
is to just put this category directly
into here.
But there's this more sophisticated
thing that we can all do
that can really give us a lot of control
into the system
which is
we apply um
category
function category
to the string.
Let's see how well writing code works in
here.
Embedding text.
Where you actually like return a custom
text for every single category that you
pass in. And that's the thing that you
embed.
And surprisingly, this becomes a really
really nice control point for us.
Because now whenever the model doesn't
return something, doesn't select the
right category, we have two areas to
probe at.
We can see one, did the model select the
right category?
If it did
then okay, that means that this part of
the system is good. If it didn't, then
we know that we have to change the
embedding text of either that category
or the one that it selected in favor of
itself. So now you have a probe points
that you can actually sit on that aren't
your whole system.
It becomes a special probe point
just either for that system. Yourself.
So if you have a category like that's
like
like for an MCP tool for like Slack and
an MC tool tool for calendars and it's
picking Slack actions when it should be
picking calendar actions
we can do different types of embedding
text as the thing that we actually
embed.
And that can be a huge unlock in terms
of your iteration loop.
Now the last thing you can do
um
the last probe point that I really want
to talk about is up here. Now once again
people often make the assumption that
the embedding text that you put into
here has to be the same embedding text
that you put into your prompt.
That's what they naively do.
But the minute that you stop doing that,
you end up in a really really nice
world. Where you no longer have to think
about it that way.
You can apply selected categories
and go through another function.
Oops.
Sorry.
The selected categories can go through
another function, which is
LLM text.
Which actually tells you how to put the
text into the prompt or the structured
output or anything that you want for the
model.
So now you we all have like two really
key
uh we have three key points that we can
go manipulate really really easily that
we can go introspect into our system.
One point becomes the text that we put
in for embeddings.
Another point becomes the number of K's
that we select
out of the vector database.
And a third point becomes the actual way
that we serialize the categories into
our prompt.
And obviously you can add more and more
sophisticated algorithms here
um in this system.
But just with these three points, we can
really make our system not really be as
much of a black box that just happens to
go do things
but make it a lot more controllable.
I'm going to pause for a little bit.
Dex, go ahead.
I got I got a question and you can
totally tell me like, yes, we'll do that
in 20 minutes or whatever and we're
getting there, but I'm curious like are
there established kind of like
structures for doing kind of end-to-end
testing on this kind of stuff so I can
change my probe or is this a thing that
people are mostly kind of hand-rolling
themselves and building a big table of
evals for every single every single
thing they they hit in production?
Well, actually you kind of have an eval
built in.
Remember like in the end what we're
passing in is we're passing the user
query as an input
and expecting some category as an
output.
Yeah.
Right. Okay, so your prompt is basically
some instructions on how to behave. It's
the user query, which is like here's the
actual thing you're classifying, and
then it's a bunch of data about like
what are what are valid what are valid
input what are valid output categories.
Exactly. And again, we can add another
probe here.
Where it's like what if the LLM doesn't
we don't we allow the LLM to pick
multiple categories?
And then we apply another method
after the fact
to pick
a single category.
So we can do multiple levels of pruning
as well. We don't actually have to pick
one. This this idea of going from many
categories to one in this scenario we
used a vector database.
But if your system is truly truly
complex
we could have the LLM pick multiple
categories and it might be really
complex cuz your categories have a lot
of overlap.
So we allow the LLM to pick all valid
categories and then we use perhaps
another LLM if we want
to actually go ahead and turn it from a
single category into multiple and from
multiple categories into a single
category.
Okay, so you could have a basically a
function there in between the category
list and the single category that is
either deterministic or
non-deterministic depending on what gets
you the best results. But having that
step there gives you it's like the the
right place to manipulate and and and
change and kind of be able to do yeah.
And this actually
this this layer here becomes really easy
to like unit test in isolation, right?
You could just say like, hey, if the
model returns these four categories and
here was the input, we should almost
always we should always be returning
this one.
Exactly. And actually this I think
that's that's the whole thing about this
whole layer.
If you If you really think about this
whole system that I built, all we all
we're doing
in reality is we're writing a function
that says pick category
or some text or some input
and we're returning a category type.
That's all we're doing. We're writing a
function that does that.
And every single technique that we
described from beginning to end
every single one of these techniques
that we described in the most simple one
of just an LLM using structured output
using a vector database to pick a
category doesn't really matter. All of
them are just implementations of this
function.
Pick category.
We just have different implementations
of this function where we add more and
more sophistication
because if we if this whole thing is
done by an LLM, then we know the only
point of input we have is a prompt.
But if we change this function, how do I
change Can you change this to mono text?
Oh, there we go. There you go.
If we change this function to suddenly
be like
narrowed
categories
equals
prune categories
input um space on the
database query.
It It could be a vector database. It
could be an LLM. It's just a thing that
reduces the number of categories from
many
to some.
But
we can we can In our example, it is a
vector database. So, I'll write that
down.
All right. So, we prune the categories
from a vector DB.
And then what we do is like we save
um
best equals
uh use LLM picker
input narrowed
categories.
And now we just return best.
That's one variation of this system.
We can We can add another one where it's
like
we can change this simply best three.
Yeah. Yeah, the same thing.
Best three and then this returns the
best
and then we go we go down there.
And we can keep on making these systems
better and better and better and just
keep on adding more steps into the
system to make it more accurate.
Is this a system that other people have
ever built before? Just out of
curiosity.
All right.
So, let's get down to
We got to kind of
to
Yeah.
Classifying for real estate.
Let's use Let's actually write this
code. I think I think the best thing to
do here is write the code um because
it's going to make things a lot
Sorry, quickly before you move on, just
a question.
Uh on the transition from user query to
the selected categories, like how are
you uh coming with the selected
categories? Are you doing a similarity
search
uh within the vector database?
can do
Exactly. So, we we can do a similarity
search from a vector database where
you'll find the top K uh out of it.
Challenges are that your user query
might not reflect the
Does it really So, so you mean to say
the semantic embeddings would fall
closer and that's how you're able to
pick it, right?
Yeah, and and if it doesn't, we can
force the semantic embeddings to get
fall closer
by changing the text of how we embed the
actual category.
So, usually what people do when they add
an embedding is they just take the raw
string and add it directly into the
vector database. They say, "Here's the
category name. Add it into the
database."
Mhm. But what if the thing that we
actually embedded into the actual
database was like this? We put the name
of the category and I'll do that over
here.
We put the name of the category like
this,
right? We put we put
uh we put the name, we put like example
uh 15 example queries that match it.
And then we put like uh another like 20
scenarios.
Um and then we put like uh like a
a list of 20 keywords.
So, now we have this ability
to almost force the embedding to be
closer to the thing that we want it to
go be into.
Mhm. Because now instead of just like
adding And how can we get these?
Literally, you can just LLM generate
these. That's what I do.
I LLM generate The initial thing I do is
I LLM generate that person.
Um
Okay. I got it. Um yeah, thank you. So,
you can actually you can actually like
LLM generate these. Or if you have a
domain expert in your company
the domain expert in your company can
actually go ahead and um go do this as
well.
And this will end up working quite well.
I've seen this work many times for many
companies that have like over 500
categories plus.
Um and the key part here is because this
becomes a thing that you control now
now you're not relying on the model to
produce the best results because the
embedding model is a black box. Neither
me or you or any of us can really
control it. Yes, we can fine-tune a
model, but like fine-tuning a model is
so painfully slow in your iteration loop
that like if you fine-tune it wrong, now
you have to go back and refine-tune the
whole
uh the whole thing.
Mhm. But if we if we have strings that
we're using to manipulate the actual
vector that we generate that we put into
the embedding system
then this becomes really really fast
to go do.
So, well,
taking an example of let's say my my
categories are a bunch of columns within
a table.
In that case, the way I'm embedding the
text here is maybe the column name and
with a bunch of description around it
and maybe a bunch of questions that it
can answer. Embedding that whole stuff
in it, is it?
Can you say that one more time? Sorry,
my headphones cut out.
Uh so, um I'm just trying to think about
an example. So, we are not going to
embed the exact text that we have.
Instead, what we are saying is describe
it in a better way, write it more
verbose maybe. I I I don't know. But
taking an example
Yeah.
Taking an example of columns column
names in an analytic SQL kind of
solution where you have to kind of
classify which columns would you use for
your SQL query.
Yeah.
In that case, multiple columns would
come and you would eventually write a
description for it. Maybe you would
write a bunch of queries that these
columns can answer and then embed that
kind of text to
here and then use that later. But in the
top if I go where you are going from
selected category categories box to the
prompt and you have this function LLM
text category in between, what is that
doing here? So, so now there's another
part. So, we have one probe that we want
to manipulate the embedding vector so we
can get more likely the categories that
we care about. Mhm.
Now there's another thing you can do,
which is the way that you put them
the text that you use to get the best
embedding out of the vector to make it
match your user query may not be the
same text that we have to do to put the
to make the LLM
pick the right category.
And recognizing that these two texts are
very different because the models under
the hood are very different
is an important distinction to hitting
really high accuracy.
Understood. Understood. So, like here,
this thing might want This thing want
might want a name
and then like a just a plain text
description
of its use.
Understood. But right, if you put in 15
examples, you're going to kind of poison
the LLM and like the do this like issue
we see in few-shot prompting where you
kind of like influence the behavior too
much.
Yeah.
Understood.
But recognize
recognize that we can have two
Now, recognize that we could use the
same function as well. It's always
possible to use the same thing. But it's
more about building probes into our
software so that when things don't work,
we have a thing to change that isn't
like praying to the prompting gods.
It's It's exactly what what I've heard
you say a bunch, which is basically is
like I don't know what the best approach
is for a given problem space, but I know
that the more control you have and the
more knobs you give yourself access to,
the faster you're going to find the best
way to solve a particular problem.
Exactly.
And what about top K here? So, I I see
me and other people struggling with the
top K value because we you are not never
sure three five. You miss it, you
under pin it and you get less
data into the context. So, is there a
way around it as well that we have
figured it out
already?
Uh pick top K.
Yeah. There's no I think that's it's
it's just a probe that you have to go
decide. And I think the best way to look
at this is now the system becomes an
introspecting system. So, if I know what
I'm expecting for a certain user query.
Let's say I'm expecting category A for a
certain user query.
And if I look at the vector database, I
see that A doesn't come out when my top
K is three.
Then then I know what I have to do is I
have two choices. I can increase top K
or I can change my embedding category
embedding text.
Or six of the other probes you have out.
Well, I do I think these are the only
ones that we can we can modify.
Can you modify LLM text? Oh, I see.
Yeah.
But it's it's it's the end-to-end thing,
right?
Well, yeah, so well, even though it's
not even if it's not coming out
end-to-end, my first approach would
actually be to see where is it failing.
Oh, you can test just between You can
test just between the user query and the
selected categories and optimize just
that loop to make sure that at least the
category that you're looking for is in
that selected batch, and then you have
fewer knobs that you have to turn. Okay.
it's not in this batch, then there's
nothing I can do about. The LLM will
never get it right.
So, at least now I have a
waterfall-based approach where I can be
like, "What It's like when I'm step
through in debugging in code."
It's like I like to know how far did I
get the right answer and when did I get
wrong. If I know that this answer has
the right system,
then I can just go work my way down and
be like, "Okay, this thing was correct,
but this thing is not correct. So, I
know I need to focus all my debugging
energy on this, not on this."
So, it allows me to know that the thing
that I should probably modify is not
embedding
text, but LLM text.
Does that answer your question, Anubha?
Yes, yes. I I think it's more around
precision K measurement kind of thing
that we do.
Yeah, and you just have to sit down and
pick the top K. Like, there's no And top
K, by the way, here is
uh is the number of vectored entries
that return from a vector database
match. Correct.
It isn't It isn't the same as top K in
an LLM, just to be very, very
particular. Yep, yep.
Any other questions from anyone?
No. Okay, let's do some code.
Um
Uh what is the disadvantage of having an
um
Can you read that question out to me,
Dax, while I set up the code? Yeah,
yeah. So, it's essentially like, you
know, what is the what is the
disadvantage of going back to zero
probes, but have two LLMs spend a few
cycles in some kind of evaluator
optimizer workflow? And then the probe
is just the stop condition for this
workflow.
Um while you're coding, I can kind of
try to tease out the question there,
Anubha, if you want to come off mute and
kind of give a little more color. Um but
it's sounds like
um I mean, I think those are just
different kinds of kinds of probes, and
your probes end up being like, "What are
the prompts, and what are the number of
cycles, and how do you have those two
LLMs collaborate with each other?" And I
think kind of the big lesson to take
away is like, maybe you don't use a
vector database. Maybe you don't use
hierarchical categories, but whatever
you use, like, how do you chunk these up
into smaller problems where you can
tweak smaller knobs and evaluate the
performance of kind of some of these
like subfunctions.
Does that sound right? Um yeah, yeah. I
think yeah, that's uh basically yeah, it
sounds right. Basically, what I'm
driving at is that I do My intuition is
that if you have a lot more probes,
yeah, it does add introspection, but
that introspection is also going to come
at a cost, right? Like, there's going to
be a cost of having one probe versus
five probes. Um
um the knobs having more knobs is going
to
also make uh
uh the debugging or introspection more
complex. That's kind of where I'm
driving at.
The only real problem Normally, I think
that's correct in software, but the diff
the big difference in the software that
I'm writing with models today is that
that ends up being way worse, because
you you actually have the worst system
right now, which is a model you cannot
modify in any meaningful way.
So, when it's a complete black box, you
have effectively no probes in the system
except the prompt. And the prompt is
just not a great
place to manipulate it when you have As
your prompts get bigger and bigger,
any individual manipulation you make
has more and more consequences.
So, if you're picking between like 100
categories
and picking between five categories,
changing the word in 100 categories is
way more likely to poison your output
than with 10 categories. And I know that
sounds a little counterintuitive.
And the reason for that is just because
you're not going to be able to
manipulate the model as quickly by
changing a word, so you'll have to
change a lot of words when you have 100
categories, and now the model will be
less likely to do what you want in other
scenarios.
So, I think the the way that I look at
this is
you end up in a scenario Sorry, my dog
is looking at me. Uh
like, when you have like less when you
have more of a model system, you basic
when you basically are like building a
really, really good Gaussian
distribution that has
really bad standard deviation. As we add
more and more probes, what we're really
doing is we're trying to we're trying to
make the curve look more like this.
We're trying to remove these soft edges
and pull the model in closer and closer.
Yeah, I mean, I I think that comes back
to kind of the core thing, right? It's
like, if you're just using LLMs and just
using prompts, like, yeah, you could
have six different prompts, and those
become knobs, and if you have smaller
Like, you could do all the vector stuff
with just, "Hey, let's loop over the
Instead of doing embeddings, I've heard
a lot of people have success and I don't
know if we'll have time to get to this
today, but like, rather than doing RAG,
just pass every single option through a
small model with a very specific prompt,
which is like, you know, "Is this
relevant to the query?" and use that to
cut the data set in half, and cut it in
half again, and do things like that.
It's like, the point is like,
the smaller and simpler the steps are,
the easier they are easier they are to
optimize, right?
Yeah, prune categories. There you go.
You nailed it, Dax. That's exactly it.
There's nothing that says that prune
categories vector DB has to be a vector
DB.
This could be a bunch of models that
take in every single category of them as
an option, like Dax said, and just
return it and select only the ones that
are relevant to the model.
Yeah. Or determine just thumbs up or
thumbs down, is this is this category
kind of relevant, or is it totally
unrelated, and just use a Boolean
classifier, right? Mhm.
All right, cool.
Um okay, let's let's I'm going to start
off writing the writing the code in very
pseudo code format, because I think it's
just going to help us know how to go
piece everything together, and then I'll
go actually go execute it and make it
work.
So, we're going to have one thing that's
going to load the categories from
somewhere. Um Dax has a bunch of
categories that we have, so we'll go
load that up in a second.
Um we're going to have a category, which
is going to have embedding text, so the
text that we use for the embedding, and
an LLM description, which is going to
use uh which we're going to use for like
the LLM.
Now, we're going to have one function
that's going to be able to narrow down
categories. So, I'm going to give it
some text and a bunch of categories, and
it should return to me some list of
categories that is here, and this
function owns everything like top K and
everything within itself. We don't
really care.
Now, what we'll do is we'll have another
function that says like
pick best category,
where we'll give it a list of
categories, and it'll pick another
category.
So, our code actually ends up looking
relatively simple.
Uh and these are all like private
functions, so
this here.
def uh
pick category. So, given a text, we
should go be able to narrow it down.
So, given some text, we're going to load
all the categories. We're going to
narrow down the categories, then we're
going to pick the best categories.
That's all this code ends up being. It's
not too complicated.
Is there Sorry, we Are we are we missing
a step that is like cuz cuz in ours it
was like
filter the list down, and then pass it
to the LLM to do the classification and
output the list.
And then Okay, that's going to go down
here.
we're not going to let the LLM pick
multiple categories right now. For now,
we're going to let the LLM We're going
to force LLM to pick just one.
Okay, cool.
So, that comes down into here.
Cool. Um and then we're going to list
that return the actual category that we
want.
Uh and specifically, let's just say like
we're going to return a string,
which is the actual name of the category
that we want. So, we'll return like
category I'm going to return
category.name, just to be a little bit
more again on what it's doing.
Um
So, now let's go ahead and go do this.
Let's implement how narrow down
categories is going to work.
So, this is going to be embeddings
equals this.
Uh
uh
Cool. That It's kind of doing this for
me.
Um
embeddings.append,
and specifically, I'm going to append
the category itself as well, so I have
access to it.
Okay, so you're a bet you're you're
appending a tuple there of of the like
the category itself becomes the label on
the embedding, right?
Exactly. So, that way I can just go look
find it really fast.
Yep.
So, then I'll embed the text, and then
I'll find like um
cosine
uh
best matches.
That's funny. It actually did it for me.
I don't know.
Um
and then this is going to return uh
sorted matches of this based on this,
and then let me just import NumPy.
All right.
So, this code is ends up being fairly
straightforward. It's just like an
embedding system, and I'm not even using
any LLM or anything. I'm I'll define
embed method later. Uh we can use any
sort of embedding system that we want.
Um
We do cosine similarity. It puts all the
categories into here. Uh and then let me
Let me make this better.
There you go.
Nice.
Um So, now we get slightly better.
Best matches.
We'll get all the best matches and then
we'll sort them and then
we'll return
What we'll do is max matches will return
like five.
So now this will actually go return
matches.
There you go. And now we're actually
going to go turn those categories.
Here.
I'm going to go turn on.
Oops. Sorry. I'm going to zoom out for a
second.
Turn on type checking mode.
For some reason Python has chosen not to
make type checking
be a thing.
By default. I mean the types are the
types are fake, right? They're all they
all disappear runtime anyways. I know,
but it's still annoys me to know it.
So now we're able to narrow down the
category.
Now I think the next part is the most
interesting interesting part, which is
how do we get an LLM to go do this for
us? Like given all this of categories,
how do we get an LLM to pick out the
right categories?
This is what I usually do.
I write a function.
Pick category.
Write a function whose job is like pick
best category. It's going to be given
some text.
And then we're going to return a
category type out of it.
And category will be an enum of
category.
But this enum is not one that's going to
be described in our BAML code. It's
actually an enum that's going to be
described dynamically at runtime.
And we'll use OpenAI
GPT-4o mini
to go do this.
Uh
Which category best describes the
following text?
So that's going to output the list of
categories that it should use
in its answer. And then as the user
message we're actually going to put in
the text. So let's just take a look at
what this prompt does really fast.
So here's what this prompt is going to
do. And I'm going to use GPT-4o mini.
Which category does this? Now there's no
categories here, so let's add the
categories at least for this test case.
Uh
type builder
dynamic
Uh and we'll write like a we'll write
like a category one
at description
for placeholder
text.
Um
Okay, cool. And that's that's being
built out kind of on the right
dynamically added to the prompt as you
add those categories. going we're
actually we're adding categories
dynamically for I don't know what is
this going to be for for
for logging.
Okay. So log levels.
So in um logs
Yep. So so when we go get our big list
of tools that we slurped up from a bunch
of MCP servers basically rather than
this category one category two category
three we'll be injecting these those
categories into the prompt like this.
Exactly. So and then if we go run this
that's what we should see that this
should in theory have picked category
one. We're good to go.
It actually said category one for
placeholder text, but we got out with
the thing we wanted, which is category
one. So I think we're good to go here.
This this function should given a bunch
of tools dynamically be able to select
this.
So now let's write this category tool.
Um So we do is
from BAML
from BAML client import
import B.
Um
Python is dumb. It needs to be reset.
Um B.pick_best_category.
We're going to pass in the text into it.
Matches. Pull this.
But now we actually have to build
build the type builder so we can
actually
dynamically pass in those categories
into it.
And what we'll do now is tb.
Uh we have our category enum that we
define programmatically in BAML.
add_value
And we're going to add a bunch of values
in here. So we'll do for category in
category categories.
Okay, cool. So at some point we're going
to need some kind of global var
somewhere to load in all the categories
from JSON or kind of just like hardcode
them in the in the source here to start,
right? Exactly.
And then what we can do is
val.description.
And we can just pass in
category.description into it.
So now that's what we that's that's our
second or third probe or whatever it was
where we customize how we describe it to
the yep, cool. Now to make sure that
that probe has really really high value,
I'm actually going to add an alias into
the system.
Where I add an alias and I use an alias
as my default one.
And what does that do exactly? I'll show
you in one second exactly what it does.
So here's what an alias does.
Let's just look at this prompt and let's
go add an alias so we can go see this.
Add alias K0 K1 K2. So it's actually
changing my prompt. It actually takes
the name of the category out of my
prompt
and only puts in
the description. That helps me in a
couple of ways. Remember we're talking
about probes. So we want to make sure
the probes we have have the most amount
of impact into our prompt.
I see. So you don't want the category
name to like cloud. You want to be
basically be like the only thing the LLM
sees is what we have selected to be the
thing that the LLM sees. And the
category name can be whatever we want
that makes it easiest to write the best
cleanest code, but that when we pass
things in the LLM we want complete
control over what the LLM sees. Exactly.
So the LLM saw K0 for placeholder text
and it was able to like it it basically
takes none of its attention metric and
puts it onto K0. It puts all of its
attention metric onto the description
that we want and it recognized that K0
is purely an identifier.
And now that it knows K0 is an
identifier it can go and like spend all
its We don't have to worry about the
nuances of words overlapping. Cuz what
if you have a category called account
issue and technical issue? And the
descriptions are very unique, but the
names kind of overlap. And single word
names tend to overlap by default. So
when you have a lot of categories, alias
can give you a lot of power building.
You can like remove the concept of
whatever that whatever like subtext the
name comes with and purely add it into
category and like let it focus on just
the category itself.
Um oh yeah. And our our example data set
has a lot of tools with very similar
names or like the same different MCP
servers have tools with the same name in
them. Exactly. And now I have a bunch of
matches and now I have to do something
slightly inefficient, which is I have to
go and like
for uh
I think that I thought it only returns
one match.
Yeah, oh sorry. But I can't use the
match keyword cuz that's the word.
Select it.
Uh category.
Uh so it has to select a category and I
do for category in categories. Return
this and then I just do this.
And this should be impossible to happen
because BAML will guarantee that this
will return one of the categories in the
list.
So this is just like triple checking
that the LLM returned something that's
in our list. Well, this is returning the
This is specifically trying to return
the type that we returned here. Ah,
you're just you're just looking up out
of our list. Yeah, okay. Yeah, I
cuz yeah, exactly. Cuz this list is
different than like the string that this
is returning.
Right. You want to return our like
native category object by matching on
the name.
Exactly. So I want to return our native
data model object for matching on name.
This is all the code is here. That's all
we have to do. And now there's clearly
things that we can do here to manipulate
both of these.
And let's can we throw in like a const
just like global list of a couple
categories? Oh yeah, here we go. Okay.
Wow, it's like cursor is listening to me
over the zoom.
Uh and right now you're clearly seeing
what I'm doing. I'm passing this in as
is.
Um
And there's no real difference here.
Um and then let me get an embedding API
really fast.
How come?
This seems like it's
installed upside down.
But yet this holds the grill.
Okay, I'm going to go and make executive
decision that's not about our uh our
problem here.
All right.
For a second I heard installed upside
down. I was like is that a comment on
the on the on the code we're building? I
also did doubt my own coding skills for
a few seconds there.
Uh okay. He's actually a plant. I I
figured we would we would give you some
self-doubt
in the middle of this this year
this year surprise challenge. Hey, look
at that.
Does it do that?
Why is it not auto completing?
There's something wrong with it, I
think.
Uh do you need to add the types for it?
Well, it's in there.
Uh maybe it's just it's just a little
slow.
Um Sorry, are you getting an error?
Uh it just says unknown and I get very
uh angsty whenever I get unknown text.
Um
of any kind. Uh and then I think
Well, I think this will work. Uh and
this was the trick.
Let's do it really fast. Let's run this
code.
Ship it.
Uh and I have my open AI key already
plugged in.
Uh UV run hello.py.
Oh.
Wrecked. Import .env.
Um can you do me a favor and just uh cat
your .env file for me just so I can make
sure you've uh set it up right?
Yeah, of course.
Oh, I didn't actually feed in the
categories. Um that was a bug.
Um I actually never fed in the
categories into my system. I actually
have to tell this function that I'm
passing in a type builder object into
it.
Oh, nice.
And we actually see exactly what this
does.
So now you can see it and it picked the
debug category. Let's add a bunch more
tools. So I'm just going to cursor to
add like
um
uh I
add 15 tools
categories here that describe user
intent
on a e-commerce
on an e-commerce
site.
This new cursor thing is annoying me to
no end. I don't know why the auto mode
never works.
Um we're almost at time, but I'm happy
to run over for a little bit if you want
to try to do this like thousands of
tools list. Yeah, let's do it right
here. So I added like I let's do let's
do this one really fast. Yeah. Um and
send you the JSON file. You can just
paste that into cursor probably and it
will generate everything you need.
So I put here I I want to buy a new
phone. We can see our like little
um
We see our little text over here and
we'll just see what this does.
How many categories I added? I only got
to pick five. So you can see what I was
able to do. It actually did search
products. I want to buy a new phone.
And now I can go and see exactly what
happened and where it happened.
So the first thing I noted is user wants
is looking for deals or discounts,
looking to search a product, looking to
add a product to their shopping cart, or
wants to sign up for an account.
Um it looked
Oh, okay. So you actually this is the
narrowed categories that came back after
the cosine comparison. Exactly. I want
to buy a new phone.
And like that looks about right if I had
to really pick one.
Uh where it's actually able to go ahead
and say
um
uh that the user wants to go pick a
product. Now, it's possible that I had a
thing in here called let's add one.
Buy
product.
Let's add that in there and let's see
what happens when I start running the
same script again.
And I can start to see kind of what's
going on.
And obviously you can do things like
cache these embeddings so everything
just for like the purpose of expediency
I'm trying to do it right here.
So the first thing here is like we can
see that now this popped up in my
embeddings list so it's actually able to
go select it. But if it didn't pop up
into my embedding list then I know what
I have to go modify. All I have to do is
modify the embedding text of the buy
product category.
Like um
do something with money. Like I'll I'll
change my category right now
to do something with money for my
embedding text.
And what we should be able to see is
it didn't pop up. So like of course the
model won't be able to select it because
it's not even one of the categories
that's available to the model to buy.
So it gives me a really nice way to go
probe it and go manipulate the system
that doesn't affect my whole system
holistically in every other outcome as
much. It allows me to tweak just the
parts that I really care about and now I
can get really fine grain control on
certain category systems.
Uh I know we're about 2 minutes left to
go.
Um I'm going to pause really fast.
Any questions from anyone?
Oh man, I got that reminder, too.
But is it
Um is is uh is LM description the thing
So you're asking is LM description the
thing it is. Let's look at what LM
description does. All I use LM
description for is
it's actually going to head and adding
text. Whenever I add the Whenever I add
the category into the LM, I'm adding
some context associated with it.
So the category often has context. And
now I can go ahead and actually add
context on exactly what this category
is.
And that's what the description is doing
for me. It's the text of the description
for that category. So the model kind of
knows what that category is used for in
context. And that text is very different
than the embedding text
because I may want to manipulate in
different ways.
And all this code will be pushed to
GitHub. I'll send the GitHub repo out
right afterwards.
Um
So all those functions we wrote as
probes of like, you know, embedding text
and we're really just encapsulating that
as fields on the class basically.
Exactly.
Yeah.
Um and like we can do different things.
We can have them saved in a database. We
can have them living in a live database
that we're constantly editing with our
users. And for example, like our users
can be given this context.
Um but that's kind of the goal here.
Question.
Yes.
You can is a video uh recording of this
going to be sent out to afterwards? Yes,
the video recording and the um and the
live code will be sent out afterwards.
And if you'd like, I'll give you some
homework uh as well to go play around
with it with the data set.
Yes. Love homework.
Yeah, there you go.
Um if you guys found this to be really
useful, we'd love for you to just go uh
give us a give us a like on LinkedIn
when you see the next one. If it sound
useful, star the GitHub repo for BAML
Human Layer. Always have to ask, it's
part of our job as founders. Um but uh
we hope that you if you send out more
questions or more topics that you'd like
us to cover next time, we'd be glad to
go do that. And then we'll stay on for
an extra 10-15 minutes answering any
questions if people have them.
Perfect. Hey, thanks everybody. And uh
y'all be hanging out as well. Yeah,
now's the extra time if anyone wants it.
So
quick question.
I'm also You have dynamic Yeah, go
ahead.
dynamic enum. So what is the purpose of
that since like
of that existing cuz at least the way
you had the example you were putting,
you know, putting all these enums in
there. So that presumes
that because it's linking to
The whole reason that this exists is for
a couple of reasons. Um so one of the
biggest reasons is as we know, the LM is
not always going to spit out the same
text every single time. Sometimes it
spits out K0.
Sometimes it'll spit out like um
like it'll say text like this, category
dash dash dash dash K0. Like this is
garbage. You if you we relied on the LM
to do this then you'd have to do a lot
of parsing. BAML is able to say that
based on the data that you gave it about
the enum. In this case we know that we
have these categories in here. We know
that the user is expecting only a
category object.
So we can run all the algorithms that
BAML runs for you and spit out just the
category under the hood.
So you are guaranteed, no matter what,
when you call this function in your
Python code,
um
this this function over here for uh pick
best category, you are guaranteed that
selected category will match one of the
enums coming out of dynamic out of the
ones that you set into here.
Got it. It helps you provide a
guarantee. And because these things are
set dynamically,
um yeah, thanks if you can put the
LinkedIn uh the LinkedIn post today's uh
session that'd be great.
If you could
um
uh if you could basically have this
guarantee then you know that this
is now a reliable pipeline that will
return one of these. So now this for
loop will always work and then
this is just uh impossible.
Yeah,
uh I think the gap was just in sort of
the
interplay between the LLM and the text
that it's injecting and what you're
playing back. And then you you literally
said it. I'm like, yeah, obvious, duh.
Okay. No, it's not obvious. I probably
said it like way too fast. I should have
slowed down. So.
Um any other questions?
Uh I have a question about latency.
Yes.
So, um you mentioned about the you know
Excalidraw diagram that you could have
like three to four different stages
where you probe. Uh so, what what is the
implication of this? I know I know
people are using open source models to
bring down costs for a lot of these
things, but they're slow. And then if
you don't use the open source models,
and you have I don't know hundreds and
thousands of API calls, that adds both
cost and latency, right? So,
uh there's a trade-off between doing too
many of those versus
increasing your application's response
time.
This approach actually ends up being way
faster from a latency perspective.
Cuz narrowing down your categories is
really fast. We're using vector
databases.
Okay.
really really fast. Right? And I'm
running this locally. You can have a
vector Most people have less than like
100,000 categories. You can run that in
memory in your machine without any other
software. You don't need to actually use
a vector database. Like you saw that I
just ran this local I I just did this.
And you just cache the vector You cache
the database file on some like random
pickle object on your system. And
obviously you can do this in TypeScript
or anything else you want as well.
But you cache
Adam, do you have the Excalidraw window
open? Could you go back to that again?
Yes, I do. The the the vector database
part I get, but the parts downstream
that part.
Yes, this part. Yeah. So, it turns out
that because the number of categories
you're sending into the LLM itself is
way less than your original kind of
categories, you also get way less way
better speed up. Because imagine you're
passing the LLM like 500 categories
versus 20 categories.
The LLM will respond faster with 20 LLM
LLMs are quadratic in nature. I mean,
exponent
like non-linear based on the number of
input tokens you have. Mhm. So, if you
have fewer input tokens, they will be a
lot faster.
Awesome. Yeah, makes sense.
And if if we change this function to
like
uh if we let's say we change this
function, and we say instead of pick
best category, we want to write the same
thing.
Uh pick best categories.
Count.
And then we return an array which cat
which
best describe the following text. And
now we can now return multiple from
multiple categories out of this system.
Uh and then we can run another narrowing
search that says given those categories,
now pick now prune it down and add more
categories into it.
If that makes sense.
Yeah, yeah, makes sense. Right? So, we
can write another function in Python
that says like pick multiple categories
and call pick best category from only
those categories. Like narrowing the
categories just happens to be a thing
that we're doing with a vector database.
You can easily call def
narrow down categories
LLM.
Oops, selected
categories.
And then I guess it did this for me.
And then let's say I want to return like
three categories.
Now I'm returning three categories from
the ones that the LLM picked. And then
I'm calling this down.
And now my pipeline
can do this.
So, I'm kind of choosing where where I
where I take in the paths of my system.
I can easily I don't have to do this
Yeah, I think um a really natural
follow-up to all of this would be like
how do you write like unit tests and
end-to-end tests on all this stuff? I
mean, I I might even be down to like on
our We have a I think we have another
topic for the next session, but we
should find some time to just like, hey,
how do you make this all the way to like
production grade engineering rigor of
like in terms of testing each individual
part and then testing the whole pipeline
end-to-end and building building up your
eval set for for how this like how we
want this to work.
Yeah, that's a good point. We should
probably consider a topic on that on how
how do you go from this to like an eval
pipeline that you can actually go and
test.
Cuz that's a whole different workflow.
You can every time the model gets
something wrong, you can quickly spin
out new tests at the like like probe
layer and at the end-to-end layer. Um
and then go iterate on your prompts or
your embedding algorithms or your top K
or whatever it is.
You want to see how I do that? I can do
that really fast.
I'll go do it really fast. Um
it this this ends up being like way
faster than most people expect.
So,
Oh, here it comes. Here it comes.
Um
let's do a little test.
I'll go do this, and in theory, let's
see if this works.
I'm going to API key.
Um Fine, I will I will ro- I will follow
up and remind you to rotate that key
before we share the recording.
Oh, yeah, that's okay.
It's okay. I already took three
screenshots. And
uh sharing options, which is
how do I stop screen sharing for like 1
second?
Uh cuz now I actually do
I think you can pause screen share, and
it will keep everything, but just like
Oh, that's great.
for a sec.
Thank you.
Um I do need to check my dot env file.
Um I'll play again.
So, here's how I do it usually.
Um
And this will give us some nice little
probes.
And what I want to do is I want to trace
this catego- this method.
And then I want to trace this method.
And then uh that one will trace for me
automatically.
Um then also trace this method
as well.
Um no, I don't need to.
Okay.
So, now I'm going to go rerun the same
thing here.
In theory,
um this should pop up and go do
something. So, we see that I want to buy
a new phone.
So, it returned search products. And
what I can go do when I go debug, and I
do this for all my eval sets
is
This is great. This is a great preview.
See the system I'm able to get, and I
can see, okay, what did narrow down
categories do? It actually returned some
of these categories. Oh, I need to
change this to our object here. The new
system does that slightly better.
And you can see exactly what the LLM
actually picked out of. And then what
you do is you can debug and say, was the
problem the fact that this didn't have
the right categories, and it didn't pick
the right thing?
And in this case, I can clearly see that
it's the case. Like I don't have the
ability to buy a product. It So, it had
to click search a product. So, clearly
something went wrong in here. So, then I
can go ahead and go and update just my
category. Then I know I have to go and
debug my iteration loop on only the only
the embedding text.
Um and really nothing else. So, I go So,
then I go and just update my embedding
text.
I think if I do it like I update it if I
make this a base model,
um
I'll play that with base model, and I
think it's slightly better. Then this
should work a little bit better.
Oops.
There we go.
Is this not working Pydantic?
You have to put You have to use the
keyword args. You can't use positional
args. I think it's also you can use data
classes. But anyway.
Oh, okay. That probably explains it. But
that's okay. I have AI to help me write
my code faster and better.
Um and then you'll basically get the
category object bumped up.
Uh and that will kind of give you more
data. And this I find to be a really
fast introspection way for me to really
quickly just understand where my system
is broken and like where it's actually
not working.
Um
And then if I rerun this again,
um oh, category has no field. This is
not a Pydantic object.
Um I may have a bug in my code
somewhere.
Cool.
Uh I'll figure out what the bug in my
code is, and I'll go update it when I go
update it. But that's the debugging flow
of being able to introspect and see
exactly which part of my pipeline messed
up is really the eval set. And really
the best eval you can have is yes, you
write down like 50 pie tests yourself,
and you call this function, you write
asserts on them.
But the best thing you can do is
actually
to let your to ship this product into
the user database and actually go and
collect this data off your real user
queries, and then go and evaluate the
pipeline and see where it's going wrong.
And if you can somehow associate that
the user intent didn't match the thing
that they did. So, if you suggested an
action based on what category you picked
and the user user said nah
on that action,
then you can always go back and say,
"Okay, then I know something is wrong.
Let me go introspect as a developer and
go see what went wrong." And I can see
was it in the narrowing down or was it
in the actually picking?
And that can help me navigate this
faster.
Yeah, and that's the thing I think in
like product dev in general is like
having having engineers have direct
access to user feedback on what LLMs are
doing. Um
super super important to like have that
tightest possible iteration loop.
Cool.
Other questions?
Available is this uh
the observability tool that we have? Is
it currently available to be on trends
as well?
Um
that will be available in about 4 weeks,
I believe. Uh and then yes, it is.
Uh we have a couple customers that are
asking for on prem, so we've been
working on that.
Okay. Okay.
And is the sign up still free? I thought
it was for school users.
it is uh it's going to be free for about
2 more weeks.
Uh
and then in 2 more weeks uh well, there
will it will no longer be free. So, use
it while you can.
Okay. Uh but we have a new version
that's even better and uh it'll have a
freemium
option on it for people that don't have
high volume of data.
Okay.
Cool. I think next week's topic is going
to be really fun. I'm really excited to
talk about the difference between like
reasoning models and like versus
reasoning prompts. Me and Dax talk about
that quite a lot.
Cuz like now these reasoning models are
coming out, the question is
is it better to offload some of the work
to the model and let it do its own
reasoning or is it better for me to
control the reasoning in my prompt like
we did today?
And
like in all things in ML,
the real answer is my favorite little
meme.
Um
Oh, they don't have it?
It depends.
Uh and we'll talk about when and where
next week and we'll have a lot of fun
and I hope uh we get to see you all
again.
Absolutely. Thanks everybody. Thanks, my
Bob. Get you all in the next one.
everyone. Dax, this was really fun.
Thank you for joining me.
Super dope. Next time you're going to
have to let me write write write some
code, too.
Yeah, we'll do it. Next time we'll have
you write the code.
Oh god. All right. I love I love it when
Vi Bob yells at me while I'm writing
code. It's one of my favorite
experiences.
Um have a great week, everybody. Catch
you all later.
Bye. Bye.